[Music] what is up there citizens of the
reject Nation we are back for Jenifer V
episode five today Johnny how are you veraciously
anticipating this Coy how are you thinking about
V and five being a Roman numeral so this is
the ultimate episode of gen V five I'll do
a GW for you I got goria guys we are going
to watch this right now leave a like on this
video that'd be very much appreciated also
be sure to subscribe click the notification
Bell to get notified on our reaction for
Gen V Episode 6 is up here on the Chanel
and as always full watch their own copy of
genv available for super sexual Rejects at
our patreon page we also cover several
things exclusively over there reaction
highlights and watch alongs included I am
ready are you ready we're all ready let's
[Music] go oh good what is that I don't trust
vague liquids in in this show going with drool
optimistically where are we you know remember
we don't I still feel like it's weird that
they have no guilt about their friend a of
saying like there's not a version that could
work I'm just saying there should be like a
hint of like is what we're doing okay a line
of dialogue just want to acknowledge we know
okay so everyone that was on scene got mind
wiped yeah that makes the most sense yeah
Dusty a llama hey SLO hey what's up guys oh
yeah oh [__] I just sorry I just thought
is that right on I just thought right on hey
hey I'm just gonna yeah sweet dude dating Jordan
it's like a twofer d we do it
little smile you happy you did
it all right I'm ready let's go again what all
right what weird thing we got in store
today what like [Music] electroshock
what
I I don't get it I yeah it's like a full body I'm
going to need I'm going to need a uh breakdown to
explain the new rock stars do a please explain
this I hate the dream this is real I think
y amazing do a girl saw it and choke me on
my misery no the family pleased to puke oh
it's going to be huge yeah lucky she has
that modesty tarp there are days that I
am missing like huge gaps in my memory mine
too what what what are you trying to remember
maybe they just had a really good party yeah
maybe those days just weren't that important
oh she's back it's smart of them to fill this in
social media wanted to plop them at a party all
places no The Keg in the foreground for size no
it just keeps getting worse and worse for her how
long have you been Snogging Jordan I don't even
know how to answer that is a male [__] tighter
than a female Jesus Emma Emma are you okay oh my
God comp Sam's just out I was out of line and I'm
so sorry do they not remember him especially after
you stopped me from doing something terrible but
I'm I'm I'm fine and how far back oh my God they
don't remember because it meant that you got away
from oh no why are you looking at me like that
oh it's me Sam the woods the the the start us
driveing look hey hey hey hey Sam that's your
name they wiped all that the blood girl I think
you're confused oh this is terrible TV or Tik
Tok or something you don't actually know us in
real life oh no this is called a parasocial
relationship they made you forget who's they
yeah good question you know there's a gap in your
memory and he's there evil people at that school
people that don't want you to know about me or the
truth and you can't trust anyone but we can trust
you she's right I wouldn't trust me either not
after what I did oh this is intriguing I'm going
to make you remember remember what that you're
a hero a a real one and a real human being I do
nothing but think of [Music] you crazy toes kind
of cute though right did you uh did you black out
last night I don't really think that's any of your
business Marie we all blacked out and not just a
party the the past few days think about it I blew
off my interview with Haley Miller but I don't
know why oh oh oh no yeah there was a kid just
now he acted like he knew me and Emma what kid
another student Sam something I I've never seen it
unless you have and forgot how come they wouldn't
wipe Sam's memory and how did he get away yeah
yeah he must have wriggled out somehow I think I
know who did this Rufus was here last night Rufus
it's all connected EA Sports It's in the game of
course it's him I wonder if he made her think
that she blew up his rich or if he actually got
his blown up blue is go we talked about you saying
the word how could you you know how sensitive job
sir YouTube I'm sorry Richard his name is Richard
I am this close to perfecting the virus a viable
way to control them for good but if they discover
that man they want to be able to permanent not
only are they psychologically controlling not now
they can permanently control them in every way how
cool that's like weaponized super soldiers I know
I love it this is what we should be spending our
R&D in America I want the girl Marie she's the
perfect subject could speed up my timeline she
is special the special but no you're not the only
one interested in Maron she has a benefactor and
because of that she's strictly off limits this
is like the New Mutants it's very New Mutants
all the subplot of this luckily no one saw that
but us yeah I was looking for something what a
nice Lounge they're all so much calmer CU they
don't have the anxiety of the things that have
been building I met him in intros pych freshman
year 3 days later I woke up at a random bed with
a camera pointed at me oh boy oh my God he saw I
was awake smiled and said make this weird and I'll
wipe you again oh my god did you tell anybody he
had me on camera consenting it doesn't matter I
don't even remember it so your body remembers
body keeps the score that's horrible so I get
him coming after me for revenge or whatever but I
go after you guys cuz he also wants to be number
one definitely must be working for them government
yeah where's Andre oh [__] Rufus whoa he's going
to kill Rufus Emma and knew is you oh my God no
girl you were L last night yeah no you got that
big soup energy big superp BSC baby someone get
her first positive interaction like with anyone
days start that big YouTube channel becoming
full though that's awesome no this a situation
but I just want to say it doesn't need to be
weird you don't need to say or do anything cuz
that scumbag mind us and we weren't acting like
ourselves yeah a I hear you um but God damn it
come on Jordan we're cool no no not cool yeah
yeah totally why are we resetting the clock on
this will they won't they that's what keeps me
in treat into a ship that's all they got me it's
a brand new R there won't they what's he doing
with Jetty let's find out wait wait wait wait
not tell he's away from Shetty what you're the
one who want to report this piece of [__] I
don't trust her oh I don't know why but I am sure
without memory you're just left to your instincts
I guess oh hey that's not suspicious get Kate
back here to make him hit himself in the nuts
all day again Jordan's so good at acting like
Jordan the casting is so like in sync yeah it's
interchangeable oh it's a mind trick
so maybe he the the D was fake it's not
him shape shifter venny what the man Rufus
gave me 20 bucks to take his shape I don't
know take the clothes too good job I think
you lost them get the [__] out of here whoa
oh yeah lock down awesome I never touched
Marie you better kill Dane de Han you hear
me want you to do the rest of us
and why and maybe I'll consider
not putting you to sleep for good
[Music] you had to know that was a
possibility hey kind of pulling up the
line there dog damn this guy has such a
powerful that is so powerful how do you defeat
that yeah it's like Xavier that's why he leads the
Xmen guess you broke the top 100 the rankings I
jumped up to 88 a my mom's been like don't get big
it's weird and gross so now I have like 20 voice
about doing a giant Cricket show a happy for Emma
kind of Jordan said we're cool they changed their
mind do you like Jordan do you want to hang out
with them do you want to talk to them do you want
to put your mouth on their mouth and other body
parts I mean come on this isn't quantum physics
oh my God you you get the best of both worlds he
great I like them I I like them but why do you
like them though we don't know that part they've
been kind of mean to each other they feel like it
doesn't even like flirtatious mean just just mean
she Jordan especially has been stopped you from
how you tell people like pry book pretty messed
up things too yep pretty direct oh clothing
Sam that weird kid he said something about a
drive-in oh is he like crouching out there wait
to isolate this kid even at least he understood
is but man what a mess this time you know what
you have to do this is bad Sam I hate television's
Jason Ritter yeah Jason R really son of a you
said you were going to save me no I'm going to
save the the real Emma not you you're you're
not puppets aren't worth saving are you like
that whoa go oh no oh this Show's
amazing a puppet fight let's go let's
go wow [Music] yes yes popcorn bullets
bullets oh by the spine finish him POV Muppet
fight oh no owie yeah yeah
somehow it's more graphic
most violent day at Jim Hansen Studios
the brain I have a single dad with two
da a
yeah D what if that helps his psyche
by turning into stting people oh yeah
buddy barehanded damn put all in the shadows and
revealing the aftermath like that
is really cool yeah that is really
cool oh it's like the Happy Time murders but
more fun yes oh man that guy Predator he said
they made us forget I mean it has to be more
than Rufus it has to be the school Rufus was
with shett what did she want us to forget
and that's why I have to go find Sam we got
to remember what we've forgotten why the are
you scratching your neck like Tyrone bigam
Warden but I have a red balls oh what
a cette respect there's blood clotted
oh injection site it's a good call it's a
good call very good call that was fast call
Bo yeah what the is that it's cuz you
got the vaccine she's got 5G for sure
definitely everything is Kate I I I I can't
soow down sleep together yes this is how it
happens he put trackers inside of us did that
Sam guy come back no I don't know I don't trust
something about how she's acting I know she's
always in her dorm being like ignore this and
I think Dean Chetty is a part of it do I have
one too yeah I was afraid of this I was oh damn
they're using her power I'm so so sorry yeah they
established that she didn't have to be like that
she gets abused it's you she's the inside she
can be controlled she becomes dismissive about
there's things about her interactions with
Andre before I was like why weird you brush
stuff under the rug and that's why she's not
weird about the Andre thing cuz she's using him
did you ask if Marie was freaked out no I just
assume that that's what she'd want that's on
you look for all you know she's cool with hiding
the sausage and bumping Donuts like sometimes I
hide in the women's showers and watch girls off
and sometimes I hide in the men's and gender is
just a construct what the [__] dude hey maning
sh it's um that's not cool shaving that's assault
go she's super pissed at me Sloan wait come on
don't be like that that's um sexual assault man
yeah a lot of it the most innocuous attitude
just brush that off yep now they going to go
sleep with the Llama the show's proba cancel
genv problematic what the hell happened to
you oh my god oh no the cycle starts again I have
no idea well no but but um cricket was there I
know I said that we were cool I don't know if
that's actually true I mean I've been doing
a lot of thinking and wait you never said oh how
far back did they wi Chase Rufus Rufus the psychic
guy he wiped you again it's like getting rufi
over and over again go kick rufus's ass yeah
I don't care I mean there's always a good
reason I mean from what we've heard I think
there's something there oh wow she's going to
ReDiscover it a weird turn of events everyone
will check in with a blonde girl yeah I forgot
her name in the heart of the moment cap cap
yeah oh my God like hypnosis oh you're the get
out get out I get it guys I get it they know
something's wrong and they're going to keep
looking and they're going to figure it out
eventually and I'm just going to you two are
the most attractive evil women I've ever SE
seen super villain models secret cabal I know
the hellfire club when I see it oh no she's
not evil she's being used to manipulated yeah
very much so but still hurt people hurt people
I tried I really tried I I knew she going to
get killed sorry sweetheart I know what I've
asked you to do is difficult she knows how to
play this like matriarch quality mm victim but
motherly all I've ever asked is that you try use
your gift for no matter how hot it gets because
you're the only one who can keep your friends
safe no matter how evil the good doing becomes
keep doing it I could learn so much from
her dude how to be manipulative 101 how to
manipulate people and whenn Friends shorter
book how to leverage trauma and Influence
People proof you were there that was the
proof that's what I'm saying that's that's
what I was oh proof oh no no proof that
you were there oh sorry it's a little
EMP a little more F would have help emphasiz
the d word earlier run out of emphasis Sam I
don't remember you no but I do believe
you I do I mean you were right someone
made me forget you well poor guy it's not your
fault she made Luke forget me too who is she
cruel oh my my God she made Luke I
think so oh yeah I think she's been
the tool for all for the whole time
I didn't even think it went that far
back and that's why they were together it
was a setup relationship by the principal
she's been with them mind wiping them
over and over again that is cruel never
mind don't feel too far lady that's his
line just Decades of trauma Scientology is
great oh my God even this drug which makes
you forget stuff everything is forget toxic
entities's John or whatever they're called
his commentary was hilarious he hated that
kid he really did the Mesmer oh
is that the Haley Joel lman one
am I wrong about that oh you're right
from like season two of The Boys yeah
yeah stay the away okay but he keeps does she
likes intervene when I got questions I swear to
Christ I never touched any of you what are
you and shy up to oh my God there's a stop
sign in the back warning us stop set deside
symbolism I wiped your memory tonight right
except I couldn't have done that because my
powers only work up close and I've been here
for the last 5 hours please tell them oh hey on
2 CB right now but that sounds right Dusty good
reveal joke no Emma's trying to wipe the memory
can't we found Rus it's not him oh wait no the
Kate is Kate em people's names it's Kate please
please don't why would you say that why would you
say that name it's not him it's Kate what that
assing crazy but it's true you sure I'm sure
okay oh W dang what damn it oh we got a villain
fight so smart Terminator oh my God to run with
me it wasn't him it was Kate [__]
Kate would never do something like
that don't tell them it isn't true fess
up I'm so sorry oh oh man I've only ever
wanted to help and protect you oh no oh
this is so sad you're all lying you're
all it back in you can't please I love you
oh getting all that back damn this is like
some Legion stuff never seen Legion but it
looks like the legion trailer this seems like
Legion understand I
didn't oh man Redemption Arc you got to redeem
yourself you can fill their back in too give a
little bop bop gonna bleed from the eyes you I Put
A Spell On You song play oh man dang she's like
Hue mine season one Huey betraying them right guys
I'm just drawing parallels and references to other
things that people have seen I got to do that
stop sign to a breakdown on you yep that's true
all right guys well all right if you're listening
to this on Apple and Spotify please go ahead rate
this video and now before we talk about this
episode which really really did enjoy I wanted
to First say Coy you're looking good in that shirt
right there like it's a nice good like it's good
fabric it's good fit it's good you know you got
and it's a little reject Nation little real re at
this and I'm a big movie theater person I like
purchasing tickets and here we are sharing the
exhibition industry that is movies so much at
the time when I get goosebumps I sometimes get
nipple chills my goodness and I can get all this
stuff at www. reation shop.com thank you guys so
much who have been watching this Channel and then
also been supporting us in one of the best ways
possible by getting yourself some awesome tees
over there we got awesome te's such as our child
protection services shirt with Pedro Pascal from
Last of Us carrying baby grou we also got this
recently launched Ahsoka snip snip lightsaber
scissors shirt we got this who influences the
influencers Watchman inspired one the other day I
cooked up a possible boys inspired tea I want to
see if I can develop it before the end of the
finale so that way it's relevant but I think
people will like it if I can get it done in time
but yeah we got a whole bunch of other shirts as
well uh seriously whenever one of these is bought
by bought whenever one of these is bought I I feel
very very proud because this is one that we are
creatively involved with ourselves it's not just
something that is just thrown out there and like
hey let's plug it now this is a a true development
of reject Nation so thank you guys it's one of
the best ways to represent yourself as a citizen
of this reject Nation but yeah let's talk about
this episode yeah I did I definitely um uh we
definitely shot this uh shirt thing afterwards
CU I forgot to mention it see if there's a GRE
did was he C us there's going to be a transition
now I got explain this ending Greg explain this
well ending explained is um you know um black guy
and black girl they had a falling out because uh
found out she's been wiping everyone's memory oh
I see I see and he explained right there explain
17 explain can't tell you Emma Emma's the bad
girl Emma's calling you're like not Emma Emma's
doing great I forget people's names Em's the one
we should trust yes Emma good M even right now
Andre no no you paused you're like Kate M we
just like IMDb up over here forget people's
names second screen IMDb so my okay that was a
really great episode all right so all right hey
I got one Theory right I mean it's a pretty
obvious one the wipe at the end of last week
yeah hey it did disorient you eventually have
to conclude that right I feel like everyone
probably concluded that yeah yeah um well my qu
I thought that was really well I mean first off
I just thought that was a really great episode um
and it was it was really uh this was probably the
most like pulsating one I would say oh I like how
tight it was there was Rhythm it was tense and it
was like that this the most edgier seat kind of
experience with it like you could feel the ramp
up I feel like while this is a great week toe
show it's also a great bin show simultaneously
because you could just feel like everything
escalating in and the frustration you feel as
an audience member of like no remember crap this
is happening yeah I I love the that pull that it's
doing and the villain I did not at all see that
I haven't even heard that theory go out there I
that was actually a fresh villain that Kate Kate
throw out a white woman name and there it is one
about to say they should really make their names
different and they could not be they are very
different Nam Emma and K they're very different
names um the uh that Kate is the villain is is
a great reveal but she's not a villain though
that's the thing is it's very comp you could
sense that there could be a Redemption for her
actions you know like there's consequences to
what she's done but I don't think as a character I
would categorize her as villainy you know because
it's so obvious that she's been used and abused
and manipulated and they even talk about some
tragic backstory stuff and certain experiences
that she's had to indicate that she is someone
you can pray upon uh which just makes it that
much more horrifying what she's going through
and yeah so like I I don't buy any stretch hate
her like I hate the actions I condemn the actions
but I don't hate her you know makes it easier
when someone's attractive to freig that's why
that's why hot therapist like I hate her I mean I
can't fudge her sensitive when you are attractive
it's just the way it Go science and when attract
people is it's brain chemistry science and when
two Attractive people team up for nefarious Deeds
you know it just becomes that much more difficult
to separate the attractive how make friends and
alien people cast people on television left and
right right and left otherwise villains can be
blamed and frankly there's no Nuance there not
at all make them hot make them hot black and white
every cast director's got that written in the back
of the head shot make them hot well there's the
answer um okay my question my question that I have
is she okay first off D explosion we'll call it
yep I don't think it happened doesn't seem like
it happened because well he's moving pretty well
you think you would be like hospitalized and be
really upset about would be like you did this to
me singing like a unic too like you don't just
get up from that so yeah unless it grows back and
we just don't know he else I can also turn I reg
yeah so okay that didn't that didn't happen and
he plants that memory or she plants that I assume
she planted that I think it's all Kate I think
Kate planted the memory of that conversation okay
so she plants that now what happens in a moment
when he's face to face with Rufus Andre and then
suddenly he's at the fast suit place that was
that was Rufus Ru Rufus is psychic so Rufus did
I think Rufus was like why are you attacking
me wipe I'm escaping yeah that's that's the
vibe I get self-defense mind that's so Kate's not
doing separate events I thought that the because
he seemed to okay yeah because he seemed he he
was yeah he was like oh [__] like he was he
was aware yeah he didn't get planted he just had
time missing and then realized when he was awake
that he was just with Rufus see I'm yeah but now
I'm very kind of I'm I'm questioning the the D
explosion scene then because that does start with
a very close proximity encounter with Rufus that
then immediately cuts to that and is in line with
other things he's done as per Kate's admission
but also in conjunction no to support your point
that is the start too of of um Jordan and Marie
actually uh that was the moment when I was like oh
they're going to sleep together yeah you know but
that could be a Kate plan maybe maybe maybe Kate
literally orated the red hering of Rufus well yeah
I'm saying I'm saying Kate orchestrated Rufus and
that whole explosion was a planted memory she can
do all that I don't know she can like completely
add memory like like create an entire narrative
I mean I guess you could if you have the power of
suggestion you could just push it to people that
yeah you you don't remember any of these events
this is what you remember and now that's just the
whereas Rufus is wiping she's adding yeah yeah no
she also wipes well yeah but I'm saying she's able
to replace whereas Rufus is just it seems like
there's just gaps in time okay cuz like Kate was
saying she woke up if that story was true which
I would I would assume it is I don't think Kate
was lying I think that's part of her experience
was that horrible situation she was in but she
didn't remember it whereas they remember things
that happened when it's Kate's doing seemingly
right yes see what I'm saying so it's implant she
talked about she talked about her experience with
Rufus yes yes yes okay that's true so maybe
maybe Kate you know cause an emotion a lack
thereof or a plant whereas he is just like all
right all right I'll roll with it all right it's
all good man I mean I like this episode I really
love the chemistry of well the salonic chemistry
really came to play here because that there was
an instinctive like I like this person I really
liked how they utilized like I just she just had
this feeling about him and that was rewarded and
I like that his Instinct wasn't like betrayal
it was I've survived them doing this to me to
to let me help you I really liked that they
their arcs feel Fuller for this episode like
Emma feels like more of a fully formed character
and then Sam also like we're getting to know him
better and their chemistry is feeding both of them
really well yeah speaking of feeding I'm glad that
Emma is getting the respect and recognition from
feeding herself Y and seeing the opposite effect
like she's becoming more full of life it's like
very metaphorical that the way they I think what
this this show has done really well is drawing
the metaphoric emotional psychological Journeys
via their powers in conjunction yeah this ruy
episode was dark like just the idea of losing
time and like being assaulted and all those things
that are I mean it was a very violently sexually
charged episode but about things that are like
traumatic and I think they utilize that well
as like a guys it's not your fault like you said
victim blaming like there was a moment where she
like blamed herself and it's it's looking at
like the villain here yeah but I don't think
that guy could run with Ed de so I I think he's
we really got to get to the bottom why make you
more aam that's true that's true yeah think of a
Kendall but with that injury like that you would
probably need time to heal mhm seemed like that
was like two days ago well they were asleep for
three or four maybe six days ago still maybe they
have someone whose superpowers is to fix these
things like my hero Academia somebody just kisses
it and then it's you know fixed or something
that's another episode don't worry they'll show
it I like this episode quite a bit as well and I
think that with you know we live in a time where
now like the run times of episodes are no longer
uniformed unless you're on like Network TV and so
sometimes that can lead to like oh here's a short
episode and it feels that way whereas this one
still felt like it was pce the right way it was
proportionate the right way and I did appreciate
that you have all these different sides of the
mystery kind of pulling out and pushing in and
you've got people's like Minds getting wiped and
they didn't use that to spin their wheels
or to like save these conflicts for later
which I thought was a nice thing it's like they
still no matter how many Minds got wiped people
are still kind kind of realizing something's up
chasing that thread or pulling that thread and so
you have these moments where you do get these you
know it's like you have the thing with um uh Marie
and Jordan where it's like oh okay so here we go
we're going to have some kind of conflict it's G
to drive a wedge between their relationship but
then they actually confront that they each have
scenes with other people to kind of get their
own conf uh you know get some guidance and then
they come back and they actually have a talk with
each other and then that kind of ties back into
the plot and then everybody trying to remember
what's going on in the woods and everything and
and The Trackers and stuff like that like again
I'm used to shows being like okay so now we're
going to wipe someone's mind or we're going to you
know have this reveal and then we're going to you
know Stave off developments for a little while but
yeah this this I thought was nicely realistically
messy under those circumstances this worked for
me in all the ways that the Mind wipe didn't work
for me when it was a mystery remember the end of
the episode we're all like that's kind of just
like like disappointing like it just didn't feel
like it was cooked this felt cooked and I really
liked I agree with the runtime I really like that
the the episode got to have this frenetic Pace as
opposed to feeling like it was just shortened or
them pacing it to hit that 50s something minute
like this I I like uh streaming allowing some
episodes are like an hour and 10 and something
can be like 37 or whatever it was yeah man this is
a great episode I really enjoy I'm back uh yeah I
didn't really leave for a second I thought Koy was
out the window guys I'm done with ch no no it just
it dipped a little bit and now it's back to where
it started for me yeah I know I thought this was
one of their best ones uh so far I think what's
interesting about this world of gen V specifically
is that the world and its purpose for serving in
the boy Universe becomes more fleshed out the more
we experience this show because like we're calling
it gen V I like the title a lot because it's the
I what I imagine the purpose of it when I think
about it is that this is the first set of people
at this school who are going here of kids who know
that their powers were given to them via science
experiment from their parents whereas before
it was like God blessed me with these Powers
you know so I think calling it gen V is is pretty
smart and this is allowing them the opportunity
to take control and make the choices of what they
can do with their powers so weirdly with the B I
wouldn't call that a superhero show it's a show
about people with superpowers under the guys of
superheroism but they're the villains of that show
yeah and then here it's like oh we actually have a
superhero show now yeah depending on how this all
goes but but I'm under the impression that oh we
actually have superheroes now this is the first
time in the boys universe that you know you got
characters like Starlight who I would and you
got people who who do good deeds and who are
do want to be super actual superheroes but this
is like our protagonists here for the most part
seem like they're good people they want to make
the right choice even with someone like Rufus
who is a terrible human being he they do not kill
him at the end of the day it's not the right call
to kill this person uh they still make the call
to not sacrifice a person's life these guys are
actual superheroes and they are taking control
of that I'm really hoping that like in the comic
there's a lot of episodes issues that feel like
episodes where there's a payoff in one and then
like later in the next Arc you meet that character
again in a new place in their life I would love if
one of these characters becomes the seven at
the end of this that beol like the finale we
find out who number one at the school is and
the number one gets promoted to the boys and
they're in the boys season four because I mean
it's all one Universe it'd be great if because I
really enjoy the product placement of the Amazon
vot situation in both shows but I've really been
lik linked to homelander Burger and stuff I would
love if we see whoever it is uh whether it's Marie
or maybe Andre whoever they get brought into the
world of the boys and then we already loved them
enough that we get to see the world of the boys
that we love meeting this character that we spent
this whole season with and go like oh how is that
conflict because then you've earned what I wanted
Marvel to do with their TV which is pay off a
long run origin with a movie payoff and then
you feel like you've really gotten to experience
An Origin story this could do that first yeah and
there's something interesting about that Prospect
too because I I think your point is is good about
the like the title is great because a I mean yeah
it is the literal descriptor of everybody growing
up under this new kind of age of knowledge and
superheroism and and everything in between but
also does hearken to jenzi and that is you know
the sort of most uh actively sort of Awakened
generation in terms of like challenging you know
the status quo and things like that and certainly
these characters are motivated to you know awaken
to and challenge you know the systems that are
being thrust upon them as normal and natural
by everyone above them in control and so you
know bringing one of these characters into a world
like the boys then subsequently I think does make
for an interesting you know a slightly different
entry way to have that challenge to the status
quo happen on that stage and that scale in a way
that yeah you can feel like you really grew with
and you understand the perspective of and that you
know could you know change that show a little bit
and also I don't know I I feel like these shows
could if everything goes well kind of feed each
other and affect each other and kind of challenge
each other to get better and sharper and all yeah
like a season 4 to lead into a genv season 2
and then like I mean I want two boys a year
and and have them be different shows like they
are yeah that'd be great well guys what did you
think about this episode what are your theories
for episode six leave them down in the comments
below do you think Kate will be redeemed do you
forgive bad people if they are attractive leave
it down in the comments below does Rufus still
have a wiener subscribe leave a [Music] like